Hi, I'm Jocelyn, and I'll be teaching
you how to add code to your mobile app
so you can track usage data,
and Google Analytics.
I'll also introduce you to Tag Manager.
Using Tag Manager, you can make
configuration changes to your app,
without having to redeploy the binary.
And you can also manage the tags
to send data to analytics.
This course assumes you know
how to build an Android app and
how to add the Google API client library
to your project in build.gradle.
The course uses a skeletal sample
app that helps you figure out
what's for dinner.
This app is already built for you.
Your task will be to add the code
to send data to analytics and
to use Tag Manager variables
to dynamically update the app.
This course focuses on how to
add code to your mobile app
to use Google Analytics and Tag Manager.
It does not teach everything
about the Google Analytics and
Tag Manager dashboards.
There are excellent
alternative resources for
learning about both of these.